because uh going back to the bold
conversation yeah and like rock
rocking and style and everything like
that so i remember i had i had to
go through this exact process when i
finished being a monk
yeah and i i was just i was just bold
right and we talked about before how you
know you can't you can't really
it's it's hard to rock a bold style
when you don't have a beard or anything
i i feel like it's especially hard as an
asian as well right
so like initially all i did was just
like wear it like
wear a beanie and the thing the thing
about this like frail asian kid
wearing a beanie walking around you look
like a [ __ ] cancer patient like
that's
that's you know that's that's that's
that's kind of like what i look like
on the outside so i was like i'm tired
of this you know i
i want to change my style right there
right so i was thinking
well what can i possibly do and the only
other
style i can think of is like what what
do you think of
when you think you know bold head shaved
you think you kind of you kind of you
kind of think of like someone who just
like a delinquent right something
yeah like a skin here like it's like a
skin head right so
i tried to go for that look and i i have
a picture actually
i i i i dug this up
during the break let me see if i can get
it but yeah i went for
i went for the skinhead look and for the
first for the first and only time in my
life
i looked like a complete i look like i
just came out of prison man
you're like asian jason
[Music]
that's [ __ ] awesome i kind of love
that
yeah yeah that is dope as [ __ ] if i saw
someone
this is the first and only time in my
life where i felt
dangerous right so i would i would be
like i would be walking down i will move
away from no no
exactly i would be because i was living
in china at this time right and so i
would be walking down the streets
and sometimes if if it was it was dark
you know
i could see like groups of girls or
groups of anyone
just like subtly cross the road whenever
i was approaching
i was like okay and this this one time
so i was with some friends there and
they took me like to this local bar
who's
run by this like frail you know you know
one of the
old asian ladies who run this local bar
yeah
and so we walk in and uh she dead ass
looks at me and i could see her have
like a mini
a mini [ __ ] heart attack she's like
what and then
she goes to my mate and goes um sorry
we're close right now i'm amazed like no
i i've been here quite often
um i you know i know this place is open
actually deadass says it to him
i'm just not looking for trouble right
now
when you say i'm not looking for trouble
i don't blame you man like if i if i was
that frail already i thought
i would think i would look at that and
be like oh that's chinese were you
wearing the sunglasses and the scarf as
well
i was wearing the scarf yeah that's
chinese mafia dude
i mean i'm not dealing with that [ __ ]
yeah the scarf says like
it's louie but i mean you know i kill
people as well
the scarf says like i'm hiding taps
you don't want to see the tats i have
under here yeah looking like this it
felt like you know that meme of that guy
in the party being like
they don't know i'm a fairly anime man i
don't know i kill people
it's like the big coat as well it's like
yeah i might be concealing a weapon but
i'll never tell this is honestly the
first time i ever like tried wearing a
leather jacket and i'm just like
damn you know what you know i'm good in
leather jackets is that why you wear
leather jackets a lot nowadays ever
since then this is where it started
yeah you're the only one i know where
it's like damn he [ __ ] kills a
leather jacket
because i've seen so many people growing
up who are like oh you know
i want to get back into like the whole
like 80s like street west
you know the punk spirit and like wear a
leather jacket and it's just
it looks so lame some people do look
like they're just wearing the dash
clothes yeah right yeah especially with
other jackets yeah exactly yeah i tried
it once and i was like nah
it's not for me